we're really glad that you made it i
know you had uh you flew in all the way
from where where'd you come from oh i
don't want to say the city because i had
a a ticket attendant a ticket person an
agent who was
unkind to me
and so i don't want to
specifically locate her in the country
but i've been on a book tour see for
about three four weeks a long time and
these book tours are worse than
they because they treat all just like in
hollywood you know they treat a writer
they treat a writer in hollywood like an
unnecessary evil and so all around the
country publishers you know they they
book writer i'm not a writer but jane
wrote the book and i was because it's my
character we went on a book tour
and um
so they booked you un unbelievably tight
you know these things are a grind we've
had people on the show
and you're just dead you're just
exhausted more exhausted i could i could
have done like 20 shows in a week 20
physical two-hour shows anyway so i get
to the airport very early in the morning
and it's raining and uh
and i'm really tired and i look bad you
know and my haircut i mean my whatever
bad haircut i had has grown into worse
length
and uh
in the cab ride to the airport right you
know and oh just in grimy you have grimy
pores everything's going wrong
and so uh i get and when we get there
the the computer is broken down so we
couldn't check in at the curb you know
and we had to take two escalators and
then two escalators up two escalators
down we had to take a tram to the other
end of the airport and when we get there
they've given away my first class seat
they just they just tossed it away
i know it's sad
the saddest story i've ever heard
and so i sew a naturally but i needed a
first i i thought i needed a first class
c but i didn't really because it turned
out that i mean i never used to travel
first class because i thought it was uh
you know um
oh it was a slap in the face of my
origins
so
then then you tasted those warm nuts and
you thought yeah
i don't care
i'm staying here so anyway well i wasn't
paying for the ticket anyway so they
booked me first class but then they gave
it away so but the woman at the desk you
know i said but we've been here for 20
minutes how could you give my seat away
because she said next time you're just
going to have to get here a little
earlier
and i said but i'm so pleased i said
please all i need is a kind word a kind
gesture i'm i'm i'm desperate i'm tired
i'm aging everything's going wrong with
my life
and i said if you and i said even if you
don't mean it or believe it at least
pretend that you care a little bit that
you gave my seat away and she says i'm
getting a little tired of you scolding
me
i love how you're looking for sympathy
from a ticket person in an airline well
i thought i thought it would be i
thought we could probably have a kind of
you know uh a psychological breakthrough
on both sides i tried not
i didn't i didn't use the word crunk
even once oh
good for you good for you i really
killed my i remained uh composed and
ladylike and um
anyway i said i'm not gonna they said
it's not ending here i have to get on
the plane i have to take this coach seat
but when i'm not stopping i'm telling it
all the way here all the way up the
runway the game plank or whatever you
call it
uh
that takes you to coach
and i'm and i'm going to tell all my
fellow passengers i'm going to tell all
your colleagues who are in the flight in
the flight attendant pool and of course
by this time
all the the news had traveled of course
so the airplane so everybody was looking
at me when i got on and um
[Music]
and all the flight attendants came over
and sort of huddled and you know
caressed me and
[Laughter]
and yeah
yeah really that was they were teasing
you gonna try this out i know they were
teasing me but
they they wanted me to feel better and
they said oh you've had a hard day and
they held me to their bosoms and things
and i had more fun in coach actually i
didn't know yeah
there's a lot of hugging in coach yeah
we did a bit uh before the show before
you came out the crystal ball which
touched on elections a bit yeah which
brought something to mind you're very i
know you're very politically active do
you have a take on uh on the elections
well the thing that when i was watching
that uh the thing that occurred to me
that made me happiest was that stars
don't have to be elected every four
years
you know i thought i thought what if
politicians had to become they got to be
politicians the way
we get to be stars uh-huh all of us oh
thanks for it yeah
thanks for including us
and then politicians would have to
endorse us and then we would have to
probably make commercials telling the
country what kind of entertainment we
were going to give them
the promises we would not want to make
no and then i wonder anyway
i'm just glad i don't have to be elected
every four years no this is a nice this
is a much better way to do it well let's
make sure we get to the book uh edith
anne it's uh called edith n my life so
far this is as told to jane wagner as
you mentioned um what would you say the
book is about
well the book the book is about me conan
yes and i have this i have this hair my
publisher said go out with your hair
just like eda
and then people will see that you are
eda
so
the book is about me and i have six
uh-huh oh six and
the thing i had most i wanted was that i
wanted my teenage sister irene
to be like all the other teenagers in
edgetown and just run away
and then i got my wish my wish came true
and as bad as i felt when she was at the
house i felt worse when she was gone
and
that i'm hoping she will come back
and so i i like to write letters i wrote
lots of letters to people to help people
uh-huh
well me and mob watch the talk shows on
the daytime
on sally's show
at maury's show
at oprah's show
on montel show
on everybody's show on ricky lake show
they have helped every family almost
every family in the in the u.s except
the beuley family
which is our family uh-huh everyone
they've just missed you yeah but i keep
riding because someday soon it will be
our family's turn
and they will help us and they maybe
like i wrote to richard simmons about my
my friend hubby matthews because he is
overweight
well richard will help him yes because i
thought maybe richard could go to
hubby's house
and go through the refrigerator the way
i have seen him go through it on sally's
and i think i'm maurice too
and then he could put he could put hubby
on a diet
and and i told richard i said dear
richard you are an inspiration to all
body types
everyone everywhere you also write
rush limbaugh in this book i noticed i
did i wrote to rush because my dad likes
rush
and do you like rush oh yeah he's
opposite us but we all have to love him
no we don't
yeah so
so here's what i said to i wanted rush
to send my dad something special like
maybe an old snapple bottle with an
autograph
and so i said to rush
i said please write that but let me say
to you rush
that i am a i am a tree hugger
and
yes and
i do not like your animal rights bumper
music
because on his animal rights update he
has andy williams is saying board free
and in the background you could hear
gunfire and you hear animals screaming
that's just russia's sense of humor yeah
that's horrible yeah and so i said i do
not want you to change your mind
i would wish you would have a change of
heart
and if i could introduce you to my dog
hug
i bet i could i bet i could win you over
to animal rights
or at least get to you get you to use
nicer bumper music yeah that's a very
good idea for rush or you could also get
richard simmons to visit rush i think
that might be
i will like them nice once
i would like to tell them to do that
wow well that's uh i wanted to ask you
uh very very quickly i know uh
we're just about out of time but i i
want to mention uh you've done so many
monologues over uh over the years you've
done so many different yeah you've done
so many different characters do you get
requests people must come up to you all
the time and ask you to do some of the
different characters oh well they um
i mean if i'm at the cleaners you know
the phone rings they'll say ernestine
it's for you
and uh
but um i you know i i there's no way i
can tell you i've tried to do every
culture type there is i
the very first monologue i ever did on
television i think was
the woman who's addicted to eating
rubber objects
and she's lucille w and she's making a
confession you know about about this
addiction she has and uh and as she's
recounting what happens to her she says
you know
one day my husband walt came home early
i was just finishing off a typewriter
eraser
he caught me with the brush sticking out
of my mouth
from then on i went right on the heavy
stuff
things started to disappear around the
house you know conan oh sure at first i
was careful
you know door stops
backs off the shag rugs
tip off mother's cane
sometimes i'd be playing canasta with
the girls i don't know what would come
over me i just jump up running the
kitchen and eat a spatula
that kind of thing yeah no one can
accuse you
when they don't apply oh wow i mean i
like it better when you act like you're
in your life what if we were in our
living room you know and your friends
are there and there's four or five
friends and everybody if someone says
something funny they oh good night
please please lily don't encourage my
audience from applauding don't
don't try and get them not to uh the
book it's it's really a fun book edith
and my life so far and uh it's by uh as
told to jane wagner people can get that
just about anywhere it was really nice
thank you very much